this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app do you
want to get paid five dollars and also
give five dollars to charity right now
if you download the cash app and enter
the reward code Congrats
you'll receive five dollars and the cash
app will send five dollars to the time's
up Legal Defense Fund cash app is the
number one finance app in the App Store
and you guys should know that so and
also you should be a part of it so
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now this episode is also brought
to you by blue apron blue apron is the
leading meal kit delivery service in the
US and while many people know what we do
many don't know about the types of meals
you eat when you cook with blue apron
well blue apron is great I use it and I
eat it and I have been eating it for
months now and you get stuff like strip
steaks with potatoes and spicy maple
collard greens and and it's just really
good food blue apron is treating my
listeners to their first three meals a
$30 value with your first order if you
visit blue apron dot-com slash Congrats
so check out this week's menu and get
your $30 off with free shipping at blue
apron com / Congrats blue apron a better
way to cook 53 that means we've been
doing it for all year and this is the
this is the second this is the second
season [ __ ] congratulations season to
baby that's how it's gonna be and we're
gonna do we're gonna keep doubling these
seasons we're gonna do see we're gonna
do first season we're gonna do second
season we're gonna double it we're gonna
keep doubling until to kill me so yeah I
am back from Tampa Florida
I love Tampa Florida okay
Tampa Florida is a very cool place and
it gets a lot of [ __ ] and [ __ ] you
[ __ ] for [ __ ] on it because
it's awesome now are there bros and
[ __ ] yeah but besides that scrape place
now I went and when I booked this I
guess weekend there I booked it - I
booked it and then I was trying to get a
room there a hotel and it was really
hard and I didn't know why and it was
because the NHL game was the the what do
you call it the all-star game was there
that weekend and also not only that
Gasparilla was there now a lot of you
guys don't know what Gasparilla is
because it's [ __ ] stupid and why
would you know want to know what
something that's so completely [ __ ]
stupid is so it's in Tampa and it's like
one day it starts in the morning and it
goes all the way through on Saturday and
it is a festival where by the way I
didn't know that music there there's a
festival where they just dress like
pirates and walk around the [ __ ] City
and then there's a parade and they're
celebrating like this fictitious
invasion this this this mythical pirate
that came in and anyway whatever the
whole thing is does matter
okay and it's real dumb because everyone
and I'm talking about like five hundred
thousand people are walking around in
[ __ ] pirate garb say yeah now you got
one leg cool
you got a parrot great you don't have
both of those things put on a shirt put
on pants do it the [ __ ] God though
right
there were news shits about on the news
and it was like we are taking over the
city it was like we're doing this and
and we you know we got in and the mayor
gave us the key and we are pirates and
like no none of that happened hey hey
another happened what the [ __ ] that's
cool except how none of it happened he
has a plane a game and it's news what
the [ __ ] it's awful
looks like a [ __ ] idiot tits roll out
and [ __ ] guys are drunk as [ __ ] then by
the way it's the most CUDA [ __ ] in the
world because these dudes this is the
most CUDA in the most CUDA thing that
ever happened in my life happened this
weekend I'm walking around trying to get
a coffee or some [ __ ] and everybody just
drunk the [ __ ] this guy comes up to me
dressed like a pirate and says to me hey
man so what's the deal with this
festival what's it about bro you're
involved hey men you dressed up for this
[ __ ] festival asking somebody who's
not dressed up for this festival what
the [ __ ]
this festival is all about hey man
you're a [ __ ] follower dude take off
your eye makeup take off your [ __ ]
pirate hat and scarf and go chill this
guy put it all on and then asked what it
was all about that's the most coup de
[ __ ] I ever was experienced super guy
walked up to me and goes are and I said
no and I kept walking dude you're not
pirates that's like did that CUDA [ __ ]
is like it's like if you [ __ ] are put
on a Marlins uniform and then you go out
onto the field you're like yo yo so
what's up with this baseball [ __ ] oh
you're ready already you're ready
already you're involved in the middle of
lovemaking
hey we [ __ ] yeah sup with this boner
[ __ ] going on what's up with me feelin
all good up in your couch hey what the
[ __ ] what says here dude you did it
you're halfway done you can't ask what
the [ __ ] going on
you idiot what's the deal I looked at my
side of what
he said what is it I said I don't know
man you got the stuff on and he's like
oh yeah but I don't really know much
about it si yeah that's cool go to sleep
go [ __ ] shopping did I don't this
thing was so dumb it was so dumb and
they told me when when I did when I did
the weekend that they're like well
Gasparilla is that week and I was like
ah [ __ ] that's uh that's gonna be [ __ ]
up for my my weekend but then I was like
you know what there's always some
[ __ ] [ __ ] festival going on it's
so annoying how many [ __ ] festivals
there are dude there's so many festivals
there's like a bottle cap festival
somewhere probably in like Fargo dude
and you know what every as a comedian
you go and you do all these things on
the road and there's always a festival
and I was there and no and I and I got
that and I got and set it up and my
manager was like there's this Gasparilla
festival thing I don't know and I was
like dude you know what [ __ ] that this
is how we do this is how we test the
cult my fans they know they don't go to
[ __ ] Gasparilla they know I've
[ __ ] daddy's coming to town you go to
the shows bro you go to the [ __ ]
shows and I thought everyone was gonna
be drunk and [ __ ] but I believed in my
cult and I was like you know what they
weren't drunk from Gasparilla cuz they
didn't go to Gasparilla cuz they know
what the [ __ ] up when daddy and
mommy's talking [ __ ]
people were like [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
Gasparilla I was like y'all pirates and
their life [ __ ] no dude it was cool man
it made me feel good and I told him this
is a cult and they all cheered yeah bro
my buddy was telling me how it's funny
that like in 20 years maybe or knowing
200 years somebody would Google that
crib that that Chris D'Elia and and
maybe think that I was actually a cult
leader and I and I and I went ha ha ha
ha but I am I am though bro what people
have two jobs
I'm a comedian and I'm a cult leader and
you guys are my babies
has any of you guys here's what I want
to actually talk about haven't you guys
ever gone
on to the deep web or the dark web
because I [ __ ] went on Google that's
all I ever go on and that's the surface
web and if you google what the Deep Web
or the dark web is the Deep Web is
apparently like more [ __ ] is like it's
like 90% of it is all [ __ ] under
what's whatever the surface web is the
surface web is like yahoo and google and
[ __ ] if you go to your websites and
[ __ ] and then the deep web is like
subscription-based [ __ ] hmm and like
stuff that's like not traceable and then
the dark web is your like if you want to
go do illegal stuff and like your you
want to look up pictures of [ __ ] kids
and like guns and sell drugs and [ __ ]
because you can't trace it and that's
[ __ ] scary dude they acquit it like
an iceberg like the tip of it like the
iceberg you can see that's the surface
weapon and a web and then all under it
is all the [ __ ] [ __ ] like the Deep
Web in the dark web and [ __ ] like that
and they run with that [ __ ] image
online if you google dark web there's
like all it's like an iceberg how many
people [ __ ] they love people love
making [ __ ] analogies bro
they love it man well we all will do get
an iceberg cuz here's the thing this
stuff you see in the iceberg and then
every how many times have people to use
that [ __ ] thing oh it's the iceberg
oh well dude this is what you see this
is the success you see but under the
[ __ ] the water that was the blood
sweat and tears the [ __ ] crying -
[ __ ] hard work determination and up
here's what you say [ __ ] off with that
analogy by the way what the [ __ ] of
microphones fallen down on fire
uh-oh one fire now here's what he'll be
like whoo you did it well don't make me
do it one fire so um yeah man I was
because I was listening to this I was
listening to this web website [ __ ] so
all so old I was I was listening to this
website you guys look at websites just
listen to websites he has to listen to
who have sight
whe be s ITES yes listen
who apps at dude anybody who talks like
that that's like quite Claire where
anything like that they have [ __ ] such
bad breath anyway um so they do cuz they
got an excuse to [ __ ] she should
[ __ ] breathe all stale at you dude
when somebody has bad breath
I want to go oh oh wait did I talk about
the time I shook the guy's hand last
week and it was clammy I ran into two
[ __ ] alright I got well I got to get
back to this [ __ ] dark web [ __ ] but I
was talking I so dude I fist bump cuz
everybody's [ __ ] hand is in there
[ __ ] and Counting money and [ __ ]
getting [ __ ] out of their teeth and
clammy as [ __ ] so I walk into the coffee
bean and I see a comedian that I like
okay and he goes what's up dude and I go
to shake his hand cuz I know the guy I
know I'm gonna have dry hands now as I'm
shaking his hand I realized he's with
somebody okay
and the guy is like hey what's up and he
extends his hand now I can't fist bump
the guy I can't [ __ ] fist bump the
guy cuz I already shook the hand of the
guy I know and that'll be really shitty
if I hit handshake the [ __ ] and then go
to fist bump the other guy cuz the other
guy's gonna be like oh I'm a piece of
[ __ ] and I look at him and I know he's
got a [ __ ] clammy hand I know he's
got a clammy hand cuz now because I can
tell cuz he was just like all I don't
know is it bad to say this but he was
all big and [ __ ] you know you know when
he walks upstairs he's just like yeah
and yet all [ __ ] in you I was like
this guy's got clammy hands but I got to
do it I'm already involved with this
other guy shaking his hand I got a
[ __ ] shake this guy hand and so I put
my hand out there [ __ ] he captured my
hand guess what happened it was a swamp
hey man I should have [ __ ] looked him
right in the eyes and been like dude
are there boats and dude are there
[ __ ] boats in your in your palm Hey
Dude do you have Hey Dude is there a
captain somewhere in your palm because
it was so [ __ ] clammy and I just and
I I grinned and bared it man and I
looked at him and I went nice to meet ya
I used it to be extra nice wash your
[ __ ] hands and don't have clammy
hands if you know you have clammy hands
put your fingers together
and [ __ ] fist bump man I got a buddy
that's [ __ ] dude he's so clammy he's
like a seal dude he's like a seal when I
whenever anyone shakes his hand every
time I see him shake someone hands I've
watched him I watch him wipe it off
afterwards the people and I go home and
[ __ ] and I said you got a fist bump
he's like no I always do but you know I
[ __ ] up I tried to but people want to
shake hands they really do anyway so I
was listening to this not website I was
listening to this podcast called sword
and scale it's a very popular one you
probably listen to it and I listen to
episode 20 which was crazy it was about
this this religious guy who used to have
this puppet show in he used to have a
puppet show in the 90s or 80s and he
would talk about being a good person and
being good purse even those free conch
he would talk about being like with the
Lord and he would use this puppet to be
like well should I the puppet would be
first of all he's a terrible ventral
because it'd be like if I started to do
ventriloquist man was just kind of like
hey guys so anyway what's going on and
he was there the creepiest puppet of all
time because if you're in the 80s and
you're a puppet you creep who the [ __ ]
ever thought puppets were a good idea by
the way puppets are the creepiest
[ __ ] thing in the world you can
firstly you got your hand up its ass
that's creepy
the hairs always and I'm talking about
puppets that are made to look human okay
the hair is always so thick and sits
like a [ __ ] broom you know and the
eyebrows are always huge as caterpillars
and the in the end the [ __ ] eyeballs
creepy and then the mouth just moves
[ __ ] the jaw just moves you know and
you got your hand up it's [ __ ] ass
cool hey who thought it was a good idea
pedophiles so so this guy is so this guy
is this you know religious yet this
religious show when he would talk about
these [ __ ] you know the puppet would
be like is it okay to like look at
pornography anyway like well no it's not
okay but maybe people will laugh at you
if you don't do the if you don't
to pornography but it's okay because you
know who is watching it's the Lord and
he'd be like ah so one person's on your
side the Lord anybody I know so okay so
it's good if Lords on my side he'd be
like yeah and of course he said [ __ ] if
he you know back then there were no
websites but he would be like website
like that's the kind of guy he was you
know so this guy I forget his name it
was like Ronald something and of course
it was Ronald because guys who were
Ronald a creepy [ __ ] and they look like
puppets dude I never there's another if
you [ __ ] have a puppet your parents
were thought about naming you Ronald
okay um anyway there's another one Ron
Lucas that's not even guy I'm talking
about Ron Lucas ventriloquist another
[ __ ] anyway so uh that's not the guy
I'm talking about Ron Lucas but there
was another guy Ron something
Ronald something and he and he went to
he would I mean what was it Ronald there
it is running Marty Ronald Brown that's
what it was so this guy this guy would
talk about being a good Christian and
[ __ ] and I mean look at the puppet look
at the puppet the biggest sideburns of
all time hey no cyber you know he kinda
looks like the good doctor the puppet
kind of looks like [ __ ] Freddie
Highmore and a good doctor or cool my
new job that I'm on is gonna now they're
gonna be mad at me so so anyway so
anyway uh the [ __ ] this guy would
would do this and talk about how good
the religion is and all that [ __ ] you
know and then was on the [ __ ] Deep
Web or dark web or whatever he was on
Yahoo Messenger so I actually was at a
surface Wed this guy's a [ __ ] idiot
but he he would start he would start he
would he was talking to this other these
other people on yahoo messenger about
you know they would send child
pornography to each other and this guy
would get in conversations about eating
children this guy Ron Brown eating
children he's like how do you how do you
eat the children and [ __ ] and then he
would talk to people who have done it
and the people be like oh I like the
thighs are the best part and oh dude it
was so [ __ ] up this episode 20 of that
is so [ __ ] up and the reason what
makes it even more [ __ ] up is they
don't have real people doing the
reenactments of the messaging they have
computer-generated voices scream pee so
it's like thighs are my favorite up hard
and it's like how old are you how do you
make these children go how do you
capture these children and then it's
like it's always good if they are
younger because they can get or way it's
so [ __ ] up it's so [ __ ] up
and then and then it'll be like I want
to eat children and then the other
person will be like YUM and they have a
robot voice go yum skip that part you
know skip that part
hey man it's okay if you want to edit it
a little bit and they have such a harsh
disclaimer they're like oh man don't
listen to this don't [ __ ] listen to
this is really really graphic okay here
we go
I'd like to eat children yum smiley face
yum they do the emojis to it they'll be
like I really love to drown children
smiley face YUM I mean it's [ __ ] up
dude and this guy's just talking about
how he wants to do it and fantasizing
about it he didn't do it but anyway they
arrested the guy for [ __ ] they gave
him 20 years for having child
pornography and pictures of [ __ ]
children that were like anyway the max
you're supposed to get for child
pornography just having it is like eight
years and this guy got 20 years cuz he
was talking about [ __ ] eating
children the judge was like yeah man
we're gonna keep you in there though
okay cuz you know why cuz you said young
dude if you say yum if you look there's
nothing creepier than looking at a child
and sanny um that that right there gets
you in jail in my world
if you're in my cult dude and you're in
the log cabin and you see a kid and you
say YUM
yes communicated dude they I mean they
were I don't even want to actually
repeat what the [ __ ] they were talking
about it was [ __ ] up it makes me feel
bad and I got some you know some
listeners here that probably wouldn't
appreciate that man they probably
wouldn't preach but if you want to
[ __ ] listen to the episode go listen
to it but man it is [ __ ] up yom-yom
what about when they're a little bit
older it is harder but still young I
just I was listening to the whole thing
I look like Butthead
you know Butthead when when they when
the weird [ __ ] when the weird music
video is playing and then a cup cuts
back to them and by heads just like this
[Music]
dude that [ __ ] was so funny but it okay
yeah and then because it'd just be like
oh yeah
like nothing's funnier than [ __ ] oh
yeah but it'll be like that's stupid and
then B will be like oh yeah it's a
follower dude anyway it was so [ __ ] up
that thing but so I looked up the dark
web in the Deep Web and [ __ ] like that
and then they were like I don't know
so crazy though that this [ __ ] that you
can look up and this [ __ ] that like I
didn't even want to like I don't like
it's weird when you see [ __ ] like like
I've straight-up never seen ever seen
the only pornography I've ever seen is
like a guy on girl [ __ ] I don't even
think I've seen I don't even think I've
seen gay porn by mistake I don't think I
have maybe like on the thumbnails like
if you're watching through the you're
going through porn [ __ ] and then all of
a sudden you're like oh that's the gay
one and if you're not if you're not gay
you don't click on it you know and if
you are gay or secretly gay you look if
you're secretly gay you look around and
then you go if you look around first and
like is this cool I'm just I'm alone I
live alone but still there's go and then
you see two dudes I remember the first
time I ever saw two gay guys in my life
I was a kid and it came on TV and I saw
two guys cuddling and I was really
really young really young and I saw two
guys cuddling and in my head I I didn't
know anything about gay I I barely knew
about straight you know I was just like
young and I had a crush on a girl when I
was a kid and so I knew about that and I
knew I was attracted to women and and I
saw two guys on a couch like playing
with each other's hair and it was so
weird to me because I had not seen it
before it was a new thing and I was like
what and I looked and that to my mom and
I said hey mom what the heck why are two
guys doing that and she said oh some
people are gay and I said well what's
that and she was like oh some guys like
each other and I went really I had no
idea and that's how I learned it and I
remember that and I thought and I looked
at it I thought YUM
two guys can be out each other's be on
each other on the couch yeah um I really
would like to be with another man young
I would like to be with a woman to come
I would like to be sexual with anybody
um I would like to eat a woman YUM I
would like to eat my neighbor come can I
eat my 46 year old neighbor Frank YUM
I would like to have you over for dinner
Phil YUM okay what's being served you
YUM so yeah so that was how I learned
about that and then I knew about Kate
gayness gay gay
the homosexual lifestyle and say yes oh
[ __ ] man I was it talking about gay
before the gay podcast we don't know we
don't [ __ ] know sometimes we go off
the rails babies that's how it goes
that's what this called does we go off
the rails babies man Tampa had some they
got they have some really they have some
bros and [ __ ] man they got some [ __ ]
bros and [ __ ] out there man it's so
funny to cuz sometimes I do this VIP
line thing like where you like do I do a
meet-and-greet like on some shows where
I sell tickets different tickets for
summer you know the tickets for the show
and then some of them like is like it's
like a little bit more to do a
meet-and-greet afterwards and I can
always tell the girl home some of the
girls that are just like a man and
trying that gum and there's so they're
it's obvious it's so obvious when a girl
looks at you and wants to and wants to
do that like you don't know because it
doesn't normally happen period in the
day it never happens and at night
sometimes I suppose it happens but you
got to understand that my show some
sometimes girls will come up and be like
you know hey so hey it's like that
[ __ ] stop yeah and then there and
then they just look and some of they had
a few drinks they just look like so it's
like they think they're being subtle but
they're just looking at me like a
[ __ ] velociraptor looks like
[ __ ] a guy in a hunting outfit just
some chick in Tampa the other the other
night the other day was uh she was just
like hey what's up she came up to the
meet-and-greet and I was like yeah she
had this drink and it was spilling all
over it was like not even close to not
spilling she was already at the point
was water was all water he's already at
the point where your friends like drink
water like that's how drunk she was and
her eyes were half-mast she looked like
a [ __ ] ventriloquist doll that that
like the and no hand was in her [ __ ]
to operate the eyes YUM
like so they were half-mast and she was
spilling water and [ __ ] and then she was
like hey and I was like hey hey hey I
grabbed their hand and I was like yo
this we got to put this down put this
drink down and I put the drink down and
then we took the picture and she was
like kept looking at me half-mast with
her eyelids [ __ ] down and I was like
okay I was like yeah you got it go ahead
bye
you know and then she was like she and
then I started talking to security like
trying to come back up on the stage
while I was taking the pictures and she
was that kress kress like that loud from
and I was like I heard her but it wasn't
loud enough so I was like okay I kept
taking pictures with other people I was
like aw thanks so much for coming you
guys really appreciate the support they
leave and in the back of kept hearing
Chris Chris Chris and the security guard
is like well I can't like touch her but
I want she's like you got to leave you
got to leave and she's just sitting
there like Chris Chris and then I was
like yeah yeah what's up I looked at her
I was like what's up and she looks at me
and she does this with the hand like
come here like the [ __ ] and I was
like III can't come there I got to do
this right now but the security will
deal with everything if you need you
know trying to be like she looked like
she wanted to eat my face YUM
I would really like to eat you Christie
oh yeah YUM your thighs are the best
party um I would love to eat your
testicles last and your lips
YUM the lips are the best part yeah
dude by the way who says yom anyway
unless you're like a [ __ ] 50 year old
schoolteacher talking about a pie what
the [ __ ] says young you know if you're
at a restaurant and the food comes and
you're like oh [ __ ] young dude you're
out see ya unless you're a hundred
percent mean it but there's no way to
say YUM without thinking ah dude I just
said YUM but if you don't think that
cool
congratulations then you meant it but
don't [ __ ] say anything you aren't a
hundred percent about man
Oh YUM I will you because they young you
imagine in Jersey saying that [ __ ] YUM
what this guy [ __ ] said young the
[ __ ] out of here you say YUM [ __ ] are
you doing one time when I was at NYU I
was at my friend's they were all from
New York and uh we were at this diner
and I put a bib I put not the bit but I
put the [ __ ] I was he can eat
something messy and I put the napkin in
the [ __ ] turtleneck and turtlenecks
what am I talking about
in my [ __ ] crew neck it was 1999 but
I put in my crew neck and then the the
napping was out and I and Tom my buddy
was so nice in New York he was like yo
get the [ __ ] out of here you gotta take
that oh yeah I'm not gonna [ __ ] say
here Nate with you are you [ __ ] with
your napkin on your [ __ ] [ __ ] take
that off and I was like yeah maybe he's
right and then Ted my other buddy was s
in New York he was like man that [ __ ]
that he's like knife I want oh wait no
no sorry like it matters but Ted said
that part about the thing and then
Thomas thought Tom was like who's even
more sinned New York he was like no I
want you to [ __ ] eat now if he wants
to eat like that I want to eat like that
[ __ ] that you you do what you're gonna
do that's so New York dude that's so
like you'll [ __ ] that ice in any would
you [ __ ] [ __ ] like that the [ __ ] you
doing take that out of your [ __ ] neck
then the other guy's like man that don't
take it out of your neck keep it there
if he's gonna do it that's why once I
want him to [ __ ] be him [ __ ] do it
don't take it out of your boob just cuz
some other [ __ ] says not to do
it and then I ate the food YUM then I
ate of the
pasta and spaghetti with meatballs in
Balinese YUM the weird part was that the
young would come right after this [ __ ]
you know I love to eat children YUM like
the word was children yum anyway um so I
I [ __ ] II don't know what I was talking
about about the the New York [ __ ] and
then and a bib was it talking about one
fire dude
Tampa and then the frickin bib and then
the girl came up to me and then the
[ __ ] some of the listeners know -
they're like ah [ __ ] we know we can't
help you though
oh well that's it dude I just told you
the New York story for no [ __ ] reason
for [ __ ] sake but this is how it is
and this is why it's [ __ ] dude some
other [ __ ] dudes get podcast they got
guests in what was I talking about I
don't know all this and that good [ __ ]
that [ __ ] this is it
we're on the phone that's how it is man
we're on the [ __ ] phone and your
speaker doesn't work and you're just
listening to me and every now and then
you're like hello hello [ __ ] it
alright let's do some ads man the cash
up the cash up is the number one finance
app in the App Store probably because
all the babies have been switching or is
it because it's the best way to pay
people back friends family co-workers
anyone really setting and receiving
money is totally free and fast and most
payments can be deposited directly into
your bank account in seconds whoops
burped
hey the square cash you know what let me
tell you some it's better than the other
guys it really is square cash is better
because it doesn't list the feed what
you do in the feed and I don't want
people to know my stuff because what if
you're in the dark web have you tried
the new cash card you got a design that
you can design it yourself via the app
it's a black debit card and the cash
card allows you to use a cash that
keeping the app anywhere you want you'll
get notifications for all payments made
with the card directly via the cash out
it's really good you can laser at your
car to personalize and they'll be
delivered directly to you for free now
right now if you download the cash app
and enter the reward code congrats
you'll receive five dollars in the cash
app will send five dollars to the truck
time's up Legal Defense Fund you want to
get paid $5 and also give $5 to charity
download the free cash out for iOS or
Android now yeah listen man I wear me
undies okay all the time every single
day you want to look good with your
significant other this Valentine's Day
don't you well then check out me undies
matching pairs it's very cool a unique
fun gift for you and your Valentine
they're the perfect balance of
comfortable fit and exciting prints
don't spend another Valentine's Day
giving the same old gift don't be lame
don't get the chocolates in the roses or
you know what you can get that but also
go to me undies comm and find the best
match for your match you're gonna think
you're gonna be it's gonna you're gonna
seem thoughtful if you do this okay oh
that's so cute
so anyway me undies is the most
comfortable and fun undies and you're
sick that you and your significant other
will ever own trust me on that
that's the crystal iasts approved
message it's three times softer than
cotton a matching pair of fun so right
now my undies has an exclusive
Valentine's Day offer from my listeners
that's my listeners for any first-time
purchasers when you go purchase me
undies matching pairs you get 20% off
and free shipping so do it now the
undies is so sure you love their
underwear they have a 100% satisfaction
guarantee if you don't love the first
pair you'll get a full refund to get
your 20% off of your matching pairs free
shipping a 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies dot-com / Congrats
that's my undies comm / Congrats they'll
be the best Valentine's Day gift that
you will give start matching your bottom
half to your better half go to me Indies
calm / Congrats now blue apron this is
my favorite way to eat men it's
literally my favorite way to eat right
now you get the meals you cook them up
you ate them it's great and you're not
you're not going out you're not you know
ordering food to be delivered from post
mates or all the other stuff and you're
not doing all it's great I do it all the
time featured upcoming meals for blue
apron strip steak and potatoes with
spicy maple collard greens what you chef
spicy chicken and stir fried vegetables
with jasmine right rice got a quick
question for you you got one of those
poufy hats you chef creamy fusilli
bukhari pasta with fried rosemary long
it's not I don't know how to pronounce
it or what it is ye chef dude blue apron
delivers fresh pre-portion ingredients
and step-by-step recipes right to your
door that can be cooked in under 45
minutes you're an in-house culinary team
blue apron is treating congratulations
with Chris D'Elia listeners to their
first three meals a $30 value with your
first order if you visit blue apron
dot-com slash Congrats
so check out this week's menu and get
your $30 off with Free Shipping at blue
apron calm / congrats blue apron a
better way to cook so that's what's up
babies thanks for listening to the
commercial break YUM I would really like
an apple right now YUM dude I was what I
was on you know I haven't seen yet is
Jumanji I was wondering about this man
two of my favorite celebrities two of my
favorite celebrities okay are the rock
my favorite celebrity is the rock okay
period
I love the rock I think he's great and I
love Kevin Hart I think those guys are
rad
I think they do cool [ __ ] I think
they're they're good they're good
celebrities and they they're you know
they seem like good people and [ __ ] and
the rock seems like an amazing person
the rock there there there never ever
stopping these two guys they do I mean
they never don't work and I was thinking
about like what is it I was talking
about
this was my my buddy and he was like
well what are they if he seems like
they're running away from something if
they work that hard you know and it's
like now I don't know if I agree with
that but what's the goal what's the goal
like let me put it this way okay I'm the
number one movie star in the world okay
I put the number I'm the number one when
we start in the world I've done all my
other movies that have been committed
they've been number one I did the
[ __ ] action movies with the rock I'm
not you know the rock right is you
that's who you are right you have
millions and millions of dollars
hundreds of millions of dollars you got
your private jet you have a family you
just had a baby which the rock did I
think last year and Kevin Hart just had
another one and somebody says hey now we
want to make Jumanji in my head I go
like this of course not of course not
not because I don't think Jumanji is
gonna be a good movie has nothing to do
with that it's probably a great movie I
haven't seen it but why why because you
want another number-one movie or because
I guess you love working I don't know I
mean I guess you could say like why do
another show but I need to pay bills too
but these guys don't need to pay bills
so what is it what is it is it to have
your I don't know my point is my point
is is they're doing and not that I'm not
trying to like do it I think the rocks
great Kevin Hart's [ __ ] hilarious at
what point does it become I guess
repetitive is what I'm saying like for
instance I did three special I've done
three specials my next special I don't
know what it's gonna be about I don't
know when I'll do it I'm not gonna do it
right now I'm in no rush but these guys
just keep churning out movies and making
money at what if like doing the same
thing over and over again is to me
just not desirable really I guess I
don't know when I go on stage I guess I
talk about different things a lot but I
mean I guess you could argue that I'm
just trying to think about this [ __ ] out
loud but like at what point like like
okay I don't have it all I don't have it
all I make I make good money I make a
good living I'm still working towards
[ __ ] like getting a private jet I don't
have it all I I don't have access to
everything I have I you know I can pick
up and go to [ __ ] Toronto tomorrow I
can do a week-long vacation in [ __ ]
France that's not it all right these
guys can literally do anything they want
to so why make Jumanji I guess is what
my question is I I want to know what it
is that drives somebody like that that's
what I want to know like what is it
about I guess they're just work like
what colleagues but why not do something
else and again I'm not I'm not talking
[ __ ] I think they're [ __ ] great but
if I'm in that situation I just would
want to do something else I think if you
can do anything you want I would want to
do a [ __ ] documentary or play a
[ __ ] weird-ass part or something you
know like Kevin Hart what he did he got
into working out and he started to like
he there's a good sense there's a good
actually example he's not the rock is
more of an example of it like Kevin Hart
is running marathons and I don't think
he did that 10 years ago like there's
something there's something that to me
is like okay yeah do something else
Kevin Hart now has this whole workout
thing hustle with heart and that's
that's uh that's to me like ah um I
would want to do like if you all of a
sudden you like like what make another
movie like yeah I make movies continue
but like that's just crazy to me just
keep doing the same thing over and over
again
I don't know people people think about
that [ __ ] though like well what's life
about like it was I hate when people
talk about like what's the meaning of
life
I like there's so many movies where it's
like well because we wanted to figure
out what the meaning of life was and why
mankind exists like what what dude
there's a question that I'm not
interested in at all what's the meaning
of life huh what do you mean what do you
[ __ ] mean what's the meaning of life
family what what are you talking about
togetherness I don't understand what do
you mean what is even that question
that question is so big and so vague it
shouldn't even exist what's the meaning
of life imagine whoever God would come
down and be like I would have [ __ ] you
that asking about the meaning of life I
don't know what the [ __ ] you mean dude
what does that mean whenever somebody
says what's the meaning of life I don't
I kind of write that person off look
what do you want me to say our family oh
yeah
we're so eating significant anyway we're
[ __ ] human and [ __ ] we're basically a
step up from monkeys chillin you know
what the meaning of life is chillin
chillin laughing being happy I don't
know what the [ __ ] you know what do you
want to hear well dude how pretentious
is it what people like yeah but what's
the meaning of life why is mankind here
what are you talking about dude go get
some [ __ ] and go get some go get laid
what's the meaning of life shut up and
me some [ __ ] fruit what's the meaning
of life get these bags [ __ ] I
hate that saying now gotta go get the
bag do you know me bags I got I'll shut
up what's up with these rappers that
don't even have an album yet they're
just talking on the [ __ ] money phone
the kid just got brick some money
pretending like they're a phone and then
I have an album yet they'll be like dude
my albums droppin next year the [ __ ] are
you you just live with your parents dude
so weird to me what's the meaning of
life dude when I was in Tampa I had the
greatest Eber ride of all time first of
all they didn't have my car to take me
to the airport for some reason they
[ __ ] up so I had to order manoeuvre so
I order an uber and tan and this dude
shows up who is you got a suburban he
shows up and he's got the [ __ ] these
these lights in them in the in the car
that are like little different colors
and this strobe like [ __ ] disco thing
and it's like red and blue and green and
no purple and we get in it's 5:30 in the
morning we're trying to get to the
airport and the guys like guys like
what's up man how was Gasparilla I was
like nah we didn't do it it was just
here for work is that God man tamp is
this [ __ ] he was like I move here
because my friend came here and he and
she and she died and then I stayed here
and I was like one star but I liked he
had an uber shirt on dude he had a shirt
on that was a collar and it said uber
and his name and this guy showed up and
I was like yo what I was like oh they
make those in my head and he was like he
was like dude he was the best uber
driver ever had hands down he was but
you know how I talk about having passion
for your [ __ ] job you're here on this
earth do what you want to do okay
live you're a [ __ ] masterpiece and
like this guy showed up in a [ __ ]
uber shirt and then he was like man I
drove a cab for a long time and I wanted
to drive this uber and I came Tampa and
I [ __ ] I you know I got this he's
like let me turn the strobe lights off
for you man if you don't want him I was
like oh I don't care he was like I just
look at it as an investment man I try to
give these people an experience by the
way I didn't ask him about to [ __ ] at
all cuz like I just wanted to give him
an experience man he was like that's why
I got all this [ __ ] and then he pointed
to all the different things it's hot in
his car like the the phone holder thing
that shows the ride and then
and like he pointed to his shirt and he
was and everytime he pointed to
different thing you'd be like investment
investment investment he pointed to the
strobe light investment he pointed to
cupholders investment the the [ __ ]
hand sanitiser investment I put it all
back in because I want these people to
be happy and have an experience and he
was like a lot of people's he's like
y'all I got the shirt I got the looper
shirt he's like you ain't ever seen you
know uber shirt he was like ain't nobody
had this he was like this an investment
I went and I had to she's like oh oh
bruh gave you those oh no I made this I
had this made I was like dude that's
awesome then he was like well I want to
give people the biggest experience of
big best experience you know what I'm
gonna go on the app right now and give
him a tip I didn't do it yet uber here
we go opening up the uber this guy was
dope
how's your trip with David gonna give
him five stars and I'm gonna give him a
tip I'm gonna give him a thirty dollar
tip did it wait okay did it because
that's an investment and I want to add
to his investment man and that's uh you
know this guy dude the guy was so dope I
just love when people love their job and
I love when people love what they do and
their [ __ ] purpose or whatever the
[ __ ] you know I don't like when people
are just doing it to do it or they do it
cuz they're good at it you know I don't
like that like I do stand-up like that
that's the other thing too like I used
to I used to feel bad about getting
upset with people when they were doing
their job but I don't feel bad about it
anymore because once I started like
doing what I love and [ __ ] working so
hard like I worked so hard dude and I
work hard and I try to give the best
show I can do it every single time I do
and so when somebody's gonna half-ass
their [ __ ] like I have no patience for
that man
I don't give a [ __ ] of what you do from
being the richest guy in the world to
not the richest guy in the world you
know I don't know let's look at the
questions ya know here we go and then
also I'm gonna look up [ __ ] up [ __ ]
up our Instagram crows of the reeks
opening up my uh-oh here's a good one
Jesus Christ okay
this [ __ ] Oh what so this is okay guys
ready for the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week this o is brought to
you by somebody who all right actually
I'm gonna read the thing first so this
is what it is if anyone ever calls you
weird just remember that humans created
normal and if we went back in time and
changed normal to your weird
everyone would be weird but it would be
normal do you man go shopping dude get
the [ __ ] out of here oh really oh you're
the first guy that said that huh in 2018
all congratulations man I'll also keep
your friends close your enemies closer
right yeah you say that too
takes one to know one is that what you
say Jesus Christ dude here's what the
picture is of [ __ ] two people and I
[ __ ] you not a guy and a girl guys got
his arm around his girl and he's they've
got I'm sure it's fake but blood all
over their face YUM they both have blood
all over their faces yeah oh cool so
it's so they're I guess they're
suggesting that if you have blood all
over your face um then you are weird but
if
we went back in time and put blood all
over our faces and said that was normal
then that will be normal and the other
people would be weird get out of here
dude YUM
oh whoa here's another one I'll do Jesus
this is a twofer I didn't remember the
bee even saving this one this guy is a
picture of him squatting pointing to the
sky already a stupid [ __ ] ass picture
don't take a picture like that don't
take a picture of you squat and pointing
to the sky not looking at the sky it's
like he's doing it like this like
goddamn your sky this is I guess a poem
he wrote I don't know it's it's not a
poem but it looks like it's written each
line is a space after it you're trying
to understand stand the sky you're the
sky you'd like to disarm your enemy you
are the enemy you want the confidence of
your hero
you are the hero you wish to manipulate
time you are time you see the perfection
in a baby you are the baby you wish to
fulfill your dreams you are the dreams
hey let's try to guess when this poem
ends and mine and I'm adding stuff to it
you do anything and everything you can
feel you can to feel alive you are alive
you try to cook all the food and make
and not be a chef you are the chef ok
that's kind of is that part of is the
part that I was a part that I made up
come on dude oh there's more pictures so
he's pointing to the sky at one or the
other one he's [ __ ] dancing on the
ground and then the other one he's
holding his his hand like this and
looking up at this guy
you trying to not not act like a
pretentious [ __ ] yeah the pretentious
[ __ ] come on dude [ __ ] out of here
did you guys watch the Grammys I didn't
watch the Grammys all I heard was [ __ ]
somebody interview lil Lucifer and they
were like what are you gonna do after
this and then he said wake up and eat
pop-tarts
cool man it's cool you gotta go sleep
first what about that what about that oh
this is a dream is that what you're
saying my friends are dead they're all
my friends are dead Santi all my friends
are dead YUM will you be eating them or
can I
perhaps dying on your friends
okay let's go to the questions what is
the weirdest thing that has happened
when you when you were doing a set oh I
had to go to the bathroom and had to run
off stage and have my opener come back
on and do it while I went to the
bathroom and then I went back and
finished the set there was nothing I
could have done I was in Houston Tom
that was at Big Blue Ridge say yep
change it Big Blue Ridge cool it change
it go did another one go the one was
okay to take old Biddy's what was the
only thing he asked about TIG ol bitties
I hate that [ __ ] John @j ma-1 underscore
how about people who say TIG old bitties
just say big titties dude everyone knows
what you're [ __ ] saying it's still so
[ __ ] crass to say TIG old bitties if
I said hey [ __ ] suck [ __ ] my suck you
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
alright don't say don't say it you know
what the [ __ ] they're saying you know
the [ __ ] my suck a [ __ ] my suck TIG ol
bitties we know you're saying big old
titties also saying ole is sin
disrespectful there's some kind of cool
though if you were having sex and you
were like ah yeah there goes build
titties like there's something creepy
and like dope about that you know every
guy knows I'm talking about to like if
you did a something weird about like
being like mid if you did that during
sex the girl wouldn't like it but I feel
like you'd like a extra what the [ __ ] is
a deal with that huh
here's that Cullen BB at BB :
do you ever bomb at this point in your
career it's tough now because people
know who you are if they're coming to
your show bombing is know it's different
it's you'll have a bad set every now and
then but bombing is different like maybe
you could bomb if it was like a tour
that I did with a bunch of other guys
and they weren't all necessarily in the
audience they weren't all my fans you
know maybe maybe if I opened up for like
Chappelle or some [ __ ] maybe I could
bomb then because it's the way
for him but like at this point if you're
at your show and all the [ __ ] babies
are out in full force you're not gonna
bomb I would have to have a mental
breakdown I'd have to be like I want to
eat kids young and even them knowing me
they're probably like yeah we know that
from the podcast huh
Keith Richardson at Keith rich for 1-9
thought some people that create social
media accounts for their animals here's
the deal
never do that period don't do it at all
it's it's it can't have it nobody gives
a [ __ ] about your dog that much you do
it therefore take those photos put it in
a photo album in your iPhone and keep it
there
that's it I got it you got a if I made
one for my dogs you home [ __ ] is stupid
that would be no never under any
circumstance even as a joke make a
[ __ ] Instagram for your pet bye I'm
not how about this unless you have an
elephant then okay I'll allow it
but you're in my cult and we're in the
LA Kevin and I notice you have in this
room for your pet you get ousted you get
ousted dude I'll do it some real Stalin
[ __ ] can't be part of it can be par by
the way I saw I saw um when I was at
guess no I wasn't even Gasparilla it was
before Gasparilla it was the day before
when I was in Tampa and this is this is
this this girl had on [ __ ] her ass
was out like she had on the these pants
and she was just wearing them and she
had a rip in her ass it was like prints
like how it like prints Howard showed
her ass it was so [ __ ] crazy I was
thinking about what if like that was
your daughter Alex Penrose at Penrose
Alex hey Chris Lea what do you think of
jay-z with hair I think that's cool he
Louie looks he looks cool he looks cool
that's a weird question but it looks
cool you know it looks good that's it
dude I think imma be done you guys are
cool thank you so much for listening
we got a poster up we gotta wrap up the
[ __ ] oh I got my two new torn-out being
announced
so I'm gonna hit all bunch of cities
coming up first I think is like
Nashville and [ __ ] and I got some [ __ ]
going on and I think I actually I'm
coming to Alabama or Arkansas one of
those I don't know those are the same to
me is that bad I don't know anyway uh
Winnipeg Calgary Saskatchewan Cleveland
are all on sale now subscribe to the
youtube channel rate and review the show
it helps us out be great if you share
the videos video episodes come up on
Tuesdays or Wednesdays and you can watch
man on fire still an incorrigible and
when my black comic thank you for
listening
and blue apron check out this week's
menu and get your $30 off with free
shipping at blue apron calm / congrats
and square cash you got a switch if you
didn't do it yet download the free
square cash app and to rewards code
reward codes rewards code Congrats and
get $5 gift $5 says times up get it for
iOS or Android now and I'm gonna be on
the good doctor tonight which is Monday
if you're listening now and then I'm on
a bunch of the good object good doctor
other sites coming up stay tuned for
life in a year which is a movie I did
and remember oh and half magic is coming
out next next month which is another
movie I did Heather Graham direction and
remember
[Music]